Kim Kardashian wants everyone to feel
the love this valentine's day including
her so-called haters oh I don't care the
Millennial mogul launched a new line of
fragrances at just in time for v-day
they're all candy heart themed and on
Thursday she was setting up to ship out
some samples as presents and all right
guys I am writing the list for my press
boxes I'm gonna send them to way more
than this but I decided for this
Valentine's Day everyone deserves a
Valentine so I'm going to send them to
my lovers to my haters to everyone that
I think of because it's Valentine's Day
after all yes in addition to pals like
Lala Anthony and Paris Hilton and Kim's
family
Kim has names like blac Chyna here's
morgana Wendy Williams and even at
Taylor Swift on her gift list in fact
all the people with blue post-it notes
are ones who have publicly beef with the
reality star including some you might
have forgotten about like Sarah Michelle
Gellar Bette Midler and Chloe grace
Moretz
wouldn't take any of it back
[Music]